I'm feeling like somebody passed where
something that they did caused how they
passed so I get that through an overdose
I get that through somebody that would
have choked they would have affixiated
drowning yeah I get it like that yeah
and then what ties to the east coast do
you have so many different ones I can't
imagine where to start anything
connected specifically to like Jersey
New York like that area yeah how
friends um can I connect can I connect
what I'm seeing to the East
Coast
that's so interesting that you say that
like
um it's just interesting that you say
that it's it's someone who's like alive
I think but maybe someone that I would
worry about dying East Coast kind of
connected to the east coast that's
interesting okay and then do you have
your own business business yeah okay in
two different divisions 30 different
divisions so two of them I feel like I
need to focus on so two of them it seems
like you're you're expanding growing
moving it feels like two of them are are
but something might
be going we might be
releasing okay and that doesn't me a bad
a bad thing so you might be selling
something there might be a a
circumstance or situation or a person
that you're involved with that that
comes to an end business-wise and you
shift something um so interesting all
positive okay all all positive and then
there's real estate in a big way there's
a whole big real estate thing for you
that's so fun that's what I want to do
when I'm a little older really get into
the real estate World well it's not it's
around the corner for you legitimately
like I feel like we're already having
conversations you were talking to people
about it you were talking about
understanding the aspects of finances
Investments and real estate in different
areas and that's so interesting I was
yeah yeah and then who's Jimmy Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy I know a lot of jimmies I
used to be a
hoe so not ready for that
response
I'm ready for like that's my
uncle I'm trying to think of a Jimmy
that stands out can I can I just ask
you focus is I'm sorry I'm Sor that's
okay yeah good day to bring your
daughter to work
huh [__]
[__] kids are
here so is your is your mom still here
um I was like adopted I wonder I don't
know the state of my like birth parents
person that you consider to be your your
mom she's still here yeah okay and
energetically you have shifted your
Dynamic with her um I shifted my Dynamic
with my birth mom if that makes sense
you know kind of cut her and my birth
father out of my life but by creating
boundaries yes exactly when I was like
probably 13 or 14 I kind of switched my
view of who my parents were to around
aded par 1819 you had to redo that you
had to yeah yeah you had to redo that so
in life there's in life there's a moment
where the Universe goes hey and I'm so
sorry I I don't remember your name Tana
Tana um hey Tana you you you learned
this over here and we're going to have
to have you revisit it over here again
so that you can go to the next level
right so it's kind of like it's like
math we don't always learn addition we
learn it and then we build upon that as
we move forward yeah I dropped out it
took me a while and I I feel for I feel
for you when it comes to personal
relationship Dynamics family personal
relationship Dynamics the energy of
where you go you become the the the lead
the The Matriarch whether you want to or
not which is why I feel like you need to
protect your energy and that protection
comes in emotional areas that protection
jokingly maybe you say you you know
dated a lot of people but it also it
comes in I'm not giving of myself I'm
not giving of myself financially
energetically mentally so you can have
the reserve I also feel like the
physicalness the digesu that you know
you were looking at like that to me
feels
like um occupational
hazard he's the the most clear this is
so cool it's just it's a part of like
you know where you're at what you're
working on um and I think you teach what
you know and that's what I do I teach
what I learn right so as I discover
something I'm like oh my God this is
really cool I'm not an astrologer I
never studied it so I made my kids learn
it right I I do I run I run something
called evolve plus. TV where I bring all
these people together cuz I don't do
this stuff but now I have access to them
and so does the community right so I
feel like we're all here to evolve and
you're in that space now do you have two
kids I do not have two no am I pregnant
no no are there's no kids for you I have
no kids okay so I see you responsible
for two so now that what does that mean
for me can I I can tell you how I would
see this okay okay um it either means
that they were two pregnancies that
didn't happen no okay um fingers crossed
nope there's seriously but this is what
the symbol means for me it means that
there's two pregnancies that didn't
happen or you will be the mom of two
kids there's like the energy of two not
dogs not cats I mean I mean kids that's
so fun so that might be that you want
children do I have children no do you
want
children I do want children so and that
doesn't and and kids happen in different
ways clearly right sometimes I've had
clients where they're like I'm
absolutely not having kids and like but
I see I see two and they're go I'm
absolutely not having kids and then they
wind up involved with somebody who comes
with kids and they have two kids oh wow
that's so there there's there's that um
and then who's the like who's like
Ashley or who is the Ash Ashley that's
my like sister my best friend okay yeah
is that's just my way of of of making
sure that I'm I'm getting that and then
are you planning to go to Spain or are
you planning to go to Portugal or why am
I in
Europe
I I don't know I'm looking at like
cobblestone streets walking through
Europe so it makes me think Italy Spain
Portugal what is that I was just there
okay like again just a validation of
what what I'm what I'm seeing for you
what the [__] is going
on I'm holding my breath I'm sorry and
then you abandoned the tattoo on your
back on the spine I abandoned a tattoo
like on my back kind of yeah I started
lasering it off what the [__] is going
[Laughter]
on it's my
it's amazing it's just a it's just a way
of backing up what I'm saying my heart
is beating out my Ching the [__] out of
me I'm going to go back to what I said
which is I just want you to protect your
energy I want you to be like really
focused on you I want to know everything
you have to say Sir she's waiting for
more I'm not kidding this is so cool
that's so crazy just I think you have a
I think you have a you have a huge level
of opportunities coming up for you but
in every opportunity we have to weigh
which is the direction and I don't feel
that sometimes you weigh
enough so it's it's actually I I agree
with that I think I spent a lot of my
life kind of just going and going and
not you know focusing on that that was
one of my big New Year's resolutions was
to be careful to say no to things that I
would normally say yes to and you know
weigh out the things that I do and if
they're worth it or not that was
actually my only New Year's resolution
and I want you to stick to that and I I
I want that to be something that you
remind yourself every day and not from
the external forces around you but from
the people that are in your circle the
ones that love you the ones that you
love your friends the ones that you're
connected to those are the ones that
will be like hey can you could you just
do that hey would you mind just just
doing that yeah and then at a certain
point you might dilute yourself you
might dilute your your own energy why
are they focusing on your feet right now
that to me makes me feel like I need to
look at your shoes or I need to look at
your feet so like are you doing anything
like I just kind of broke my toe yeah
they're making me feel like I need to
focus on again anything I'm getting
around you about self-care so you said
that you're legitimately working on
sobriety correct yes so that to me is
all self-care yeah and creating
boundaries important for for self-care
and by the way for anybody listening
that's navigating grief that's self-care
making sure that you're working on
honoring how you feel cuz we have to
feel to heal and deal yeah I completely
agree and understand who's the brother
well he's like my best friend his his
family adopted me he's here actually
okay and is his is his dad passed no so
is that the J
family can he can he can hear me I don't
know if he can hear you you can maybe
hear is he back
there so is he there like if he's
listening to this is he going like yep
that's her yep that's her like yep I get
that um how would you know yeah I I
assume so he like he knows everything I
know and he's like a brother figure for
you right yeah hi there hi how are you
all right talk closer to the mic what
are you what are you getting hello I'm
just I don't know if you're able to hear
what I was saying about her okay were
you able to hear what we previously
discussed yeah okay can you just I'm
just curious like factually you you
understand what I'm saying about her
yeah
okay where's the J name around your
family who has the J sound living or
past um an older half brother okay is he
is he passed no but I have an oldest
brother that did pass that you your
brother's here coming through around her
so I'm supposed to acknowledge one happy
birthday to show me a celebration
his birthday just passed like 4 days ago
oh my God I'm crying that's so crazy
yeah he's making me feel like happy
birthday oh that's so crazy and then do
you know like when somebody gets lasered
you know when somebody gets like lasered
stuff done oh God I'm shaking I'm
shaking and crying so is there anybody
that works with lasers or like laser
lights or oh my God that's so crazy did
you do anything to honor him with
lasers no not with with lasers like
balloons like sending them up into the
sky I want to acknowledge the
illumination where the lights is how I
want to acknowledge it so I want to be
very clear I don't mean flashing lights
and flicking lights I don't mean it I I
that's what I mean I mean like there's
something about like seeing the lasers I
kind of feel like if I'm at a an
amusement park or I'm at a place where
there's like a disco with flashing
lights and like lasers and or neon
lights neon lights would do for me like
there's something about that okay is
something symbolic and are you the baby
boy of the family um no I want you to
put him into this as well and there's a
split family right you have a split
family two older half Brothers her and
then two like younger siblings okay and
is Mom still living yeah can you let Mom
know that he came in and make a
reference to to Mom and that is that his
biological mom um we have two separate
moms okay but his mom's living yes his
biological mom yeah I need I just saw
her yeah I need you to let his
biological mom know that that that he's
okay and you have his shirt correct you
took the
shirt
no yeah he's telling me you have the
shirt folded it was folded up in the
drawer the shirt like I thought you
going to tell me you just had it yes
like you were just looking at it or just
remember he wants me to bring up the
shirt did you know him too the brother
not really okay so there's a reference
to that you you have the shirt and take
I have a bunch of his stuff like folded
up in a drawer and I did just see that
but I don't think there was a shirt he's
telling me to talk about the stuff in
the drawer to me it feels folded up he's
telling me he was with you he likes the
new apartment or the the reference to
the new place that you you moved or
there's a reference to that and then
he's talking about either you were going
to Mexico and didn't or there was a
reference to something about Mexico and
it got moved or he was going to Mexico
and it got cancel somebody was going to
Mexico and it got moved or canceled are
do you think that when he just said to
me about like Italy or like Cobblestone
that that's cuz we were we were supposed
to go to Mexico yeah or well no to Italy
or to like Spain that's what I was
thinking when he was saying that I was
like Wow and then you know do you have a
wallet wallet no so I'm supposed to I
did yes I'm supposed to tease you about
your wallet wallet and never bringing it
and like going places without your
identification crazy so be careful about
travel if you're traveling somewhere
make sure you have make sure he has his
passport or or his his wallet um and
then was he
bipolar I think we all are no I mean
like was somebody diagnosed like they
needed medication I don't think he was
like ever diagnosed so he had very very
high highs and very very low lows
uh it's not him who's
Chris who's no no no no who's Chris they
tell me to tell you Chris who's Chris
someone I know is Chris still here yeah
okay so you get what I'm referencing
then yeah but I want to know more okay
I'll tell you
later okay wow okay your brother's good
you're
amazing
he